hey everybody we're back i'm here with
molly ringwall
now what is the deal let me ask you what
is the deal with the brat pack now is
the brat pack is that thing completely
dissolved now do you guys keep up with
each other you know is there a
newsletter that you can
i was never really sure what the bat
pack was to be honest i mean it the the
the phrase was coined by a clever writer
when he went out to dinner with i think
judd nelson and rob lowe and
emilio estevez i think right and then
sort of everybody that was in those
movies became a bratpack member right
there was a time like in the i guess
it's the mid 80s where that's all you
would read about is the brat pack went
here and did this the brat pack ate a
sandwich together the backpack
went swimming somewhere yeah well you
know we did a couple movies together but
um but i didn't really hang out with a
lot of those people just because i was
younger at the time i mean when i did
breakfast club i was 15 16 years old and
they were already in there they're all
much older now judd nelson is in his
late 50s now i think
it's true no he's on medicare it's true
no no no no no he's had both hips
replaced i'm just telling you
you've been away you don't know what's
going on i'm just telling you no but but
i i was quite a bit younger so when they
were going out you know drinking and you
know doing crazy stuff i was going to
school so okay so you think they'll ever
be a big reunion where they they get you
guys are all in your 80s or something
and they get you guys together and you
it could happen you never know
well we'll wait we'll look forward to
that 60 years from now that's going to
be good you got started very young
didn't you in show business you were an
annie is that right i was yeah okay i
didn't play annie
i i was just wanted four bucks
who were you i would say i would think
you were annie you look like annie no no
i was one of the orphans i was just one
of the the chorus oh one of the kids in
the back yeah oh and how old were you
when you got started doing that um i did
that when i was 10 years old
i started when i was um well i started
as a singer because my dad bob bringwell
is a jazz musician so i started singing
with him and then that kind of led into
plays and then that led into movies and
now was that pressure when you're a
child star i mean or when you're a child
getting into acting you actually have to
worry about
if you have a growth spurt or something
like that you know when you watch the
the old brady bunches or something and
cindy suddenly had that growth spurt and
look yeah it got scary there for a while
it really did people were frightened but
what i'm saying is is that a hard thing
to go through is that you know were you
worried about that when you were 10
years old if i grow too fast or don't
grow fast enough well i think it was uh
it was a problem obviously if you if you
grew i mean when you're
all the there was the littlest one and
then there's the oldest orphan and i was
i started out as the second to the
littlest and then sort of the more you
grow
the oldest one gets booted out and then
the next one takes over and then so it's
like menudo okay yeah yeah
yeah exact same thing yeah and so once
somebody got to be the oldest orphan
they knew okay in three months i'm gonna
be one inch taller and then i'm out so
yeah it is a lot of business yeah it's a
lot of pressure for a young person so
when your feet start to really get big
you know you're in trouble yeah that
means you're gonna have a gross did you
grow very tall because you're quite tall
well i grew six inches in one year that
year that hurts yeah that's really yeah
yeah but then i stopped after that i
sort of reached my full height at about
you know 12 or 13. i grew literally i
grew like a foot and a half or two feet
in a year well you never stopped i mean
you're still going i was bombarded by
radiation
government test site yeah it's not
pretty but it's not bad being tall right
well it's really hard when you get tall
that fast because at one point in my
life i was six feet four
155 pounds
and that's it's just it's like a puppet
in a big parade you know
it's just
they called out japanese tanks to shoot
on me it was
did you ever think about basketball or
anything i mean i was into i was
interested in basketball but you know
what i found out you need coordination
it's something i didn't know yeah i was
like i showed up and i was like i'm six
foot four let's go let's let's get
started here and then they realized i
was a freak and it couldn't go on
i'm not winning you over with this stuff
am i
women love to hear this stuff all right
well there was
i guess 19 in in the early 80s and into
the mid 80s you were really the
quintessential
american teen i think for a lot of
people
what kind of pressure is that for you is
that thank you
i mean it is
it is that has to be some kind of odd
pressure because everybody sort of
projects their ideal you know teen on to
you did you find that to be a
pressurized situation well it was just
funny because i was always trying to be
something else i mean i
i i guess the success of those movies
were just because the the characters
that i played felt so out of place and
they were always an outsider you know
ugly duckling and all that and i guess a
lot of people feel that way so i sort of
became the poster child for that
and um you know which isn't so bad you
know yeah but uh but i mean i mean the
16 your character in 16 candles so many
people latched on to at the time and
said i know what that's like yeah
yeah it wasn't really that much of a
pressure i mean i i thought it was not
it was just funny i mean when i saw
people cutting their hair like me or
dressing like me it was just it was just
funny because i always picked other
people to to emulate and to you know
like diane keaton and annie hall was my
idol when i was
that age so i was trying to look like
her you know and probably she i don't
know she was probably trying to look
like someone else but you know everybody
does that there's very few people i
think you'll meet that say i'm great i'm
perfect the way i am and
you know except for you maybe yeah
that's right yeah
i don't say that a lot
no i wouldn't last long in this world if
i did that is that by the way this is
just just a quick question but the song
we were talking about this in the break
but the sponge song
molly 16 candles yeah everyone's saying
that's about you
yet there are other people saying it's
not about you do you know if it's about
you or not uh i don't know i mean the
song's called molly and they talk about
16 candles i mean one would think you
know but uh but i don't know there's no
uh there's no proof and i don't know the
guys who wrote it so i like the song
though yeah because if it is about you
you should get some money coming
and i'll split it with you because i
brought it up okay all right well let me
make sure i mention uh the french comedy
is the film that you did uh you you
pronounce it because i'm like a fool
myself uh that's your movie
come on enfonz salud
yeah okay all right very nice all right
well thank you very much i like it when
you speak frank
molly ringworld everybody
friend leibowitz big audio dynamite
coming up it's a good show we'll be
right back